Well, guys, I am so honored. I am joined today by the absolute royalty of golf podcasting. Honestly, royalty of personalities, too, if I'm being fully honest, the co-hosts of We Need a Fourth, Kenny May, Brian Baumgardner, and my boy, Cooper Manning. Boys, welcome. I'm so excited for you guys. I'm so excited for the podcast.
各位，我感到非常荣幸。今天加入我的是高尔夫播客界的绝对大咖。老实说，如果我完全坦诚的话，他们也是个性界的顶流，他们就是《我们需要第四人》（We Need a Fourth）的主持人：肯尼·梅恩（Kenny Mayne）、布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳（Brian Baumgardner），还有我的好兄弟库珀·曼宁（Cooper Manning）。伙计们，欢迎你们。我为你们感到非常兴奋。我非常期待这个播客。
Thank you so much. This is great. We've been having a blast. This is the threesome that we didn't know we needed in America. And then when I tell people that you guys are doing this podcast, everybody's very excited. You all love golf to varying degrees. Explain a little bit about your relationship to golf.
非常感谢。这太棒了。我们一直玩得很开心。这是我们在美国之前没意识到自己需要的三人组。当我告诉人们你们在做这个播客时，每个人都非常兴奋。你们对高尔夫的热爱程度各不相同。稍微解释一下你们与高尔夫的关系吧。
Well, first off, well, I would say that Kenny loves golf. the most for sure. Like I don't think, I think Kenny loves golf more than Cooper and I love golf combined. He just needs to learn how to play it. So, yeah, I mean, that doesn't love me back. Now, I'm a disabled senior and I play back way back with those guys from the tips. So keep that in mind. I'm just, that's not fair.
首先，我会说肯尼绝对是最爱高尔夫的。我觉得肯尼对高尔夫的热爱超过了我和库珀的总和。他只是需要学习如何打好它。所以，是的，我的意思是，它并不爱我。现在，我是一个残疾的老年人，我总是和那些家伙从发球台打起。所以记住这一点。我只是，这不公平。
I'm trying to learn. I'm trying to learn. I got a lot more to learn, but I do love the game. You know, I was going to ask you about your hockey team up there in Canada. and whether you get distraught. I get incredibly competitive. When it's over, I'm done. Like, it's not, it's not like, I don't carry the joy or the pain for longer than like 25 seconds.
我正在努力学习。我还有很多东西要学，但我确实热爱这项运动。你知道，我本来想问你关于你在加拿大那边的冰球队的事，以及你是否会感到心烦意乱。我非常有竞争意识。当比赛结束时，我就结束了。就像，我不会把快乐或痛苦持续超过25秒。
Right. And Coop, you don't get, you're not very competitive in that way. Like, golf for you is a lot of fun. You like to have fun. I mean, you like to bet or whatever, but. I've gotten to the point where I do not like playing golf. As much as I love playing golf, I do not like playing golf. I do not like playing golf with people I do not like, and I won't.
没错。库珀，你在这方面不是很争强好胜。对你来说，高尔夫更多是乐趣。你喜欢玩得开心。我的意思是，你喜欢打赌之类的，但是。我已经到了不喜欢打高尔夫球的地步了。尽管我热爱打高尔夫，但我并不喜欢打高尔夫。我不喜欢和我不喜欢的人一起打高尔夫，我也不会那样做。
Someone can invite me on the greatest trip. We're going here, and I'm like, who's going? And if it's a bunch of bozos, Coupie is out. I'd rather go play an absolute muni with two guys wearing football jerseys and smoking weed and get a story out of it than some stiff at, you know, some fancy schmancy spot. Well, that makes sense. And this podcast, obviously, is, you know, we need a fourth, so it's golf-centric. But you guys kind of delve into, it's safe to say that you guys go on tangents that aren't necessarily golf-related.
有人可以邀请我去最棒的旅行。我们要去这里，我会问，谁会去？如果是一群傻瓜，库珀就不去了。我宁愿去一个绝对普通的球场，和两个穿着足球衫、抽着大麻的家伙一起打球，并从中得到一个故事，也不愿去什么高档的地方面对那些死板的人。嗯，这说得通。这个播客显然是围绕高尔夫的。但你们似乎深入探讨了，可以肯定地说，你们会进行一些不一定与高尔夫相关的话题。
I know there's an upcoming. And we also get very deep. As you, you know, interviewed with us, I mean, we talked High-Lye, we talked Canadian football. We talked about your love of hockey and your love. We try to, we want the whole person. We're peeling back. there's nothing left of the fucking onion by the time it's minced and and we break the person down I guess I like the social aspect of it I love that for that time you're out there
我知道有一个即将到来的节目。我们也谈得很深。正如你采访我们时所知，我们谈到了高球、加拿大橄榄球。我们谈到了你对冰球的热爱。我们试图展现完整的人。我们正在剥开洋葱，当它被切碎时，洋葱已经所剩无几了，我们剖析了这个人。我想我喜欢它的社交方面，我喜欢在那段时间里你在外面。
there's nothing to do you're not on your phone you don't have a million things coming at you you're just there and you get to kind of shoot the shit and have a good time and that's that's what I like and that's kind of the vibe that you guys have here on that's what we're trying to do I mean we're trying we're looking for a fourth to play golf with but really we're just looking for a fourth to hang out with um And like you will, for me, golf, I, I don't do yoga. I know that's surprising to a lot of people. This is, by the way, this is breaking news, but I was going to be the name of this show.
那里什么都没有，你不用手机，没有一百万件事向你袭来，你只是在那里，你可以闲聊，玩得很开心，这就是我喜欢的，也是你们在这里营造的氛围。这就是我们试图做的。我的意思是，我们正在寻找第四个人一起打高尔夫，但实际上我们只是在寻找第四个人一起消磨时光。而且对我来说，高尔夫，我不做瑜伽。我知道这对很多人来说很惊讶。顺便说一下，这是突发新闻，但这本来是这个节目的名字。
I don't do yoga. He's more a tight sheet. I don't do yoga. But I use golf as meditation 100%. Like you get four hours and you're thinking about nothing, you know, not work, out family, not whatever distract you. on your phone, but you're just focusing on putting this little stupid ball into this
我不做瑜伽。他更像是一个紧绷的家伙。我不做瑜伽。但我把高尔夫当作100%的冥想。你有四个小时的时间，什么都不用想，你知道，不用想工作、家庭，不用想任何让你分心的事情。不用看手机，你只是专注于把这个愚蠢的小球放进这个
little stupid hole, and that it totally resets me. But don't you think as a man in the world you live in today, there's rarely a scenario where you're going to spend four hours with three other guys doing something everybody's enjoying and not, you can't
愚蠢的小洞里，这完全让我重置了。但你不觉得作为一个生活在当今世界的男人，很少有场景能让你和另外三个家伙花四个小时做每个人都喜欢的事情，而且你不能
hide from getting a read on someone. If you spend four hours playing something, you're going to find out a lot, like, is this a good fellow? Do I want to hang around him again? what's he you can you find out because you can ask him anything and it's always fun I usually learn a lot sometimes no people don't ask me anything in return I went well I got that guy figured out but he doesn't know shit about me that's fine too I like that well it's also sort of like I forget which comic does it it's we have the joke here where all come home and my wife will ask so how's so-and-so doing you know is he dating anyone like I don't know he fucking he had an 82 he had a good day like you know yeah Kenny, that is so funny you say my buddy, I don't play golf with anybody more than I do with
躲避对某人的了解。如果你花四个小时玩某样东西，你会发现很多，比如，这是一个好伙伴吗？我想再和他一起玩吗？你可以发现，因为你可以问他任何问题，而且总是很有趣。我通常学到很多，有时不，人们不会问我任何回报。我心想，好吧，我搞清楚那个家伙了，但他对我一无所知，那也很好。我喜欢那样。嗯，这也有点像，我忘了是哪个喜剧演员说的了，我们这里有个笑话，我回家后，我妻子会问，某某怎么样了？你知道，他在约会吗？我不知道，他妈的，他打了82杆，他度过了美好的一天，你知道，是的，肯尼，你说得太搞笑了，我的伙计，我和任何人打高尔夫的次数都没有和
our pal, Jason Bateman. J.B. Jackie Bates. And his wife, she'll double back on me. We'll play and then we'll have dinner that night. And she goes, what? Jason didn't tell me any of the stuff that you're telling me. I asked him and he didn't, she goes, what do you guys talk about? I go, I don't know. We're just, you know, we're just
我们的朋友杰森·贝特曼（Jason Bateman）多。J.B. 杰基·贝茨。他的妻子会向我打听。我们会打球，然后那天晚上一起吃晚饭。她说，什么？杰森没告诉我任何你告诉我的事情。我问他，他没有，她说，你们聊什么了？我说，我不知道。我们只是，你知道，我们只是
shooting the breeze. Yeah. Next shot, ribbon each other, having a laugh about something. But we don't, you know, you don't get too deep. It's not like, you know, we don't tee off and go and start walking and go, hey, man, you know, I just, I'm really depressed. Doesn't make for a great day. Things are not good at home. She's an eight or seven. Exactly.
闲聊。是的。下一杆，互相调侃，对某事开怀大笑。但我们不会，你知道，你不会谈得太深。不像，你知道，我们不会开球然后开始走着说，嘿，伙计，你知道，我真的很沮丧。这不会让这一天变得美好。家里情况不太好。她是个八分或七分。没错。
Mark, our producer, should be noted, is a stick. He's a very good golfer. I play with him many times over the years. and he reminded me of a story one time we were playing years ago in New Jersey which Coop I know you like I could almost stop there in New Jersey in New Jersey I could almost just stop there right this is like 10 15 years ago in New Jersey
马克，我们的制片人，应该指出，是一个高手。他是一个非常好的高尔夫球手。多年来我多次和他一起打球。他提醒我一个故事，有一次我们多年前在新泽西打球，库珀，我知道你喜欢，我几乎可以在那里停下来，在新泽西，在新泽西，我几乎可以在那里停下来，这大约是10到15年前在新泽西
Mark and me in Chris Pratt TV and films Chris Pratt who we adore hilarious guy great guy funniest dude in the room and Pratt about the second or third hole I forget what it was his a shot and he's like who threw my back out and he says, I'm, he says, I'm going to go in. We're like, you want to say, no, no, you guys keep going. I'm just going to go in, and let me just go deal in, and I'll see you guys later.
马克和我，还有克里斯·帕拉特（Chris Pratt），电视和电影里的克里斯·帕拉特，我们崇拜他，搞笑的家伙，很棒的家伙，房间里最有趣的人。帕拉特在大约第二或第三洞，我忘了是什么了，他打了一杆，他说，谁把我的背弄伤了？他说，我，他说，我要进去了。我们说，你想说，不，不，你们继续。我只是要进去，让我去处理一下，我稍后再见你们。
So Mark and I continue to play. We play a full 18. We're coming in, it's kind of like twilight. We're coming into 18, and just behind the 18th green, we see this thing, this being lying on the ground with his knees up. And it's Pratt, and he's been waiting there for hours for us to come in, lying on the grass just beyond 18. By the way, we drove him back to the, because we were his ride to the city. We drove him back here to New York City. He gets out of the car bent over, and he walked there, and he's like, see you, man, that was a great date.
所以马克和我继续打。我们打满了18洞。我们回来时，天色有点暗了。我们来到第18洞，在第18洞果岭后面，我们看到这个东西，这个生物躺在地上，膝盖弯曲。是帕拉特，他在那里等了我们几个小时，躺在18洞后面的草地上。顺便说一下，我们开车送他回，因为我们是他的顺风车去城里。我们开车送他回纽约市。他下车时弯着腰，他走在那里，他说，再见，伙计，那是一次很棒的约会。
Fully bent over. I love when people get hurt. I don't know why. Pain and a grown man. I saw a guy kill a goose once. I saw a guy off a tea at Dyker out in Brooklyn off the tea. This guy was a terrible golfer, and he hit a goose and he killed it. I had two clients one time I was playing with, and one guy was up ahead in the bunker.
完全弯着腰。我喜欢看人们受伤。我不知道为什么。痛苦和一个成年男人。我曾经看到一个人杀了一只鹅。我看到一个人在布鲁克林的戴克（Dyker）发球台，这个家伙是个糟糕的高尔夫球手，他打中了一只鹅，把它杀死了。我有两个客户，有一次我和他们一起打球，一个人在前面的沙坑里。
trying to figure out something and someone's just absolutely hit this shin high two iron right in the lower back and the guy went oh you know goes that and those two started getting in a fight and i just said you know i just laughed my face off by the way you just said i love when someone gets hurt that's like doing something you know they're supposed to be doing you know like well that's why you guys both ridicule me for the leg brace i got a ruin you will doesn't know this i got a right ankle from football way back when so i wear this leg device that lets me do stuff with no pain these guys and j b the jasoner those they killed me for it's like okay let's go make fun of wheelchair people next guys i know but you carry it you carry it around like you're carrying an
试图弄清楚一些事情，有人绝对用二号铁杆击中了那个人的后腰，那个人哦，你知道，发出声音，那两个人开始打架，我只是说，你知道，我只是笑得脸都僵了。顺便说一下，你刚才说我喜欢看别人受伤，那就像做某事，你知道他们应该做的事情，你知道，就像，嗯，这就是为什么你们俩都嘲笑我戴的腿部支架，我有一个伤口，威尔不知道这一点，我因为很久以前的足球比赛右脚踝受伤，所以我戴着这个腿部装置，让我在没有疼痛的情况下做事情。这些家伙和J.B.，那个杰森，他们因此嘲笑我。就像，好吧，让我们去嘲笑坐轮椅的人吧。伙计们，我知道，但你带着它，你带着它就像你带着一个
an urn of your dead uncle like walking around like that ankle yeah so guys listen we're really excited about we need a fourth this is going to be this is going to be a lot of fun uh when it when is it drop. September 15th. September 15th is a drop date. Thank you, Bomber. This is our only. Every Monday. Every Monday.
你死去的叔叔的骨灰盒，就像那样走来走去，那个脚踝。是的，伙计们，听着，我们对《我们需要第四人》感到非常兴奋，这将是非常有趣的。它什么时候发布？9月15日。9月15日是发布日期。谢谢你，轰炸机。这是我们唯一的。每周一。每周一。
Dropping two on the 15th. So there'll be two there if you're listening to this on the 16th. Drop it on the 15th. Jop. I mean, let's reword that. I don't think it's going to give us the best. Deuce on the 15th, fantastic. We need a fourth.
15号发布两个。所以如果你在16号听这个，会有两个。15号发布。Jop。我的意思是，让我们换个说法。我不认为这会给我们最好的。15号发布，太棒了。我们需要第四人。
Brian Baumgartner, Kenny Mayne, Cooper Manning. Guys, couldn't be more excited. Sike for you guys and can't wait to listen. Thanks so much. much, man. Thank you. Thank you.
布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳，肯尼·梅恩，库珀·曼宁。伙计们，不能更兴奋了。为你们感到兴奋，迫不及待想听。非常感谢，伙计。谢谢。谢谢。
Thank you. Smart. Bless Media. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。Smart。Bless Media。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。